dion sanders is uh the the head coach of
jackson state
university
uh football team obviously uh though he
was a two sport athlete yeah he played
baseball but he wasn't as good he wasn't
as good yeah he was good but it's hard
to do prime time not prime not prime
yeah yeah so uh he is has a
responsibility as the head coach of a
football team especially a college
football team to educate these young
boys remember this is not professional
sports this is collegiate sports and um
he brought in brittany renner
thought of the century thought of the
century yeah
to
have a conversation with these boys
about what women could potentially do to
them i thought that [ __ ] was fire did
you i thought it was absolutely
brilliant remember they can make money
now
that's right
so the so that's right so the college
kids now can make money they have these
potential advertisers sponsorships etc
there's going to be girls like brittany
renner who are out there potentially
targeting them i don't know if she's
admitted to targeting because she was
wifed up with
pj washington yeah yeah but she kind of
admitted his targeting what was she
saying she was like oh if you want to
come up off a check go with an athlete
they're super dumb yes but she didn't do
that about pj washington she did that
[ __ ] years before exactly yeah but then
she did that kind of and then she ended
up doing it yeah so it was like kind of
targeted right to be fair to her like
she was
wifed up with him like i think they
named the kid pj washington junior like
yeah so there was some [ __ ] that went
out it doesn't matter i just thought it
was dope and i think that this is
something like i think the nba tries to
do this like they try to educate you
they do right yeah so like but they do
it financially so it's like oh here's
how you get all your money in order here
you put money away for retirement and
[ __ ] like that but he's doing what
counts he's doing what counts but here's
the thing
how do you lose the most money if you're
a player yeah
that is the financial planning
[ __ ] maintenance
that's what you're gonna lose all your
money right savings it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
savings
it's gambling yeah right gambling you
can lose crazy money but a lot of these
athletes like i guess they can gamble
but there are certain restrictions
gambling though right you're like i hope
i pull out on
yeah imagine having like the
unbelievable athletic ability of an
athlete like the fast twitch muscle
fibers that athletes that's the problem
but they can't just fast switch out like
they know but they probably think i'll
get out in time
sperm is faster twitch
no matter how slow you are bernie kosar
headphones on his fast twitch love his
fast twitch
twitch
crazy are we really gonna make this
happen because we're gonna make it for
everyone else
that you didn't want to come did you
didn't want to [ __ ]
in general
yeah opposite oh whatever it doesn't
matter we're not going to talk about you
anymore god forbid because you know when
we're talking about him he's he's
calculating how many minutes that he was
spoken about
technically i should be paid for those
seven minutes and i provide you guys
with entertainment on the podcast and
that is part of the [ __ ] running
ledger it's part of the ledger is it not
also vala keep an eye on his computer
make sure he's not looking up things or
hotels to stay at
show me the computer right now let me
see the computer
read the message read the message the
westin no it's the w
it's literally the westin right there
that is crazy duff but what are you
doing read it
um
i'm literally saving you money in that
email right now money you're gonna
remind him of later absolutely
that's why he's so quick to show you
i would like everyone to submit comments
on andrew's profile like if it's if
i'm giving you should i allow him to
wear his uh religious paraphernalia no
wedding i get one thing you either step
on the glass i wear the shawl or wear a
keeper you pick i'm also wearing keeper
why
you made
but he's not you don't get to dictate
the religion at his wedding yeah that's
the problem why are you hiring me that's
why that's what i'm asking why are you
hiring him why am i hiring i'm good at
it
you are good at it yeah it'll be the
most i got to speak without you cutting
me off
here today
youtube subscribers and [ __ ] plummet
yeah that's right
you should put it on patreon he's trying
to convert you bro do you think that's
what it is i think you know
that's what i think throw a little water
on youtube
[Laughter]
see i thought that i was doing you a
favor at this i thought the girls would
see you up there and you'd be looking
all beautiful and the sun is sitting
behind you so we can't see the bald spot
there's just all these
that andrew advantages you really care
about andrew where are yankees fitted at
the wedding if you really care about
anyone we'll be matching then
let's go
i'm just so scared i'm gonna look so
much better than at the wedding though
he's gonna look sharp at the wedding
yeah he's gonna look really sharp i wear
the same thing every day on his podcast
yeah what do you think okay the okay
what is the over and under what is that
saying
[Laughter]
someone called dave porno how do you do
gambling no what is the
are you over two hold on are you over
two pay me a hundred dollars for every
pound under i am no no no no then he's
going to lose the weight you can't do
that yeah that's a motivation that i
already am at yeah because he's saying
he's like 180 or something no
[Laughter]
what are you at
187 189 yeah really i fight to stay
under that number dude yesterday i want
to say this this is and i want to say
this as a friend who's like
100 i want to say he's a friend who's
concerned because i do mean this and i
want to have a kind of information about
this i mean this sincerely yes
yesterday right we listen listen
this is seriously this is serious
okay and then listen then we're gonna uh
actually acknowledge that
we'll see your trunk
okay so this is i mean this seriously no
i'm just being serious here
yesterday i saw something that concerned
me
okay
he hadn't eaten remember we had a call
right we had a call about the podcast
right he's offline texting during the
call i'm starving like i remember this
am i breaking down i haven't eaten since
9 00 p.m the night before 9 p.m
9 p.m
that's not that that's not early like
yeah if you had dinner at like 5 p.m the
night before then that day no it was not
it was two o'clock it was two o'clock
he didn't eat from nine people
broke
two o'clock the guy is falling apart we
sit down he's already ordering by the
time i get to 15 hours right he goes i
have to eat bread i haven't eaten since
9 pm i didn't say bread you did you go i
would like he goes i'll have a fried
chicken sandwich french fries and then
fried green tomato everything was fried
wow mark ate it what's going on mark is
trying to gain weight yeah though oh
okay mark is getting brolic as [ __ ]
actually he's getting brolic as [ __ ]
okay and you what do you look like you
eat fourth meal every single day fourth
of every single day
i don't eat bread and i had gumbo
i had i had gumbo i had one and a half
balls of gumbo and i passed out for two
hours of media oh yeah you almost there
i know there was something in that gumbo
derek came in i know dove probably told
him do this derrick came in and wake me
up and i was like all right problem up
he's like all right bro should i just
kind of hang out in here i was like okay
and then i was like i got a shower he's
like yeah i'll just hang out over there
and i know 100 dove is like go in the
room
and don't leave the room until he walks
out of the [ __ ] hotel did you say
that the people of jacksonville
everything
by the way one of the best shows i've
seen you know it was a lot of fun dude
jacksonville is great
jacksonville is a lot of fun shout outs
a little duval a little duval oh yeah
yeah yeah he's the [ __ ]
energy you were great bro yeah maybe he
was inspired man all this is inspired
greatly by a little duval yeah like he
really and he's just the [ __ ] man
dude guy flies his own plane to the show
that's incredible his schedule is so
funny he's like the show was at like
nine and he was like 7 30. yeah yeah but
it was nine o'clock we were talking he
was like yeah i'm gonna be in my bed by
12. i was like where's your bed he's
like atlanta yep fire he's like yeah i'm
just fire as [ __ ] dude i got life
figured out yeah
he's the [ __ ] man and he's inspired
so much of this the road like even the
way that like i tackle comedy and so
many people are inspired by him that
they don't even realize it so huge shout
outs to doable but uh serious note let's
address the elephant in the room shall
we yeah oh wait real quick can i say one
thing about dion please i didn't i
thought this was great recruiting by him
for other athletes oh genius because
realistically jackson state is good for
what they are but how many of those guys
are going pro gonna make millions of
dollars he's recruiting
other players
brittany renner not trying to [ __ ] no
jackson state university athlete yeah
she's [ __ ] dudes who play bama
yeah kentucky ball players you're gonna
do that as a football drill you go to
the bar see brittany runner and try to
resist her yeah yeah like oklahoma you
gotta turn around right there and then
that's gonna [ __ ] try to power
through that's kind of smart that's kind
of like this he's better at recruiting
young talent than brittany renner that
[ __ ] is about it dog she's
[ __ ] way more better dudes than he's
recruited
she's way better at writing tonight
her roster is better than his roster in
terms of getting players to play you
could put athletes versus athletes you
think he's got better or worse players
than she's [ __ ] he's got worse players
than she's [ __ ] yeah yes wow just give
him time yes i just give him time yes he
gonna get i don't think that any of the
players on his team start on hers
damn
yeah like not yet that's an interesting
game young britney like no hold on
that's interesting like whose [ __ ] got
the best start in five yeah wow like
honestly kendall jenner
jenner
blake blake griffin i think was it kuzma
too
it was always like hanging around with
them yeah she got some she got some some
joints
brittany renner though she got capped
she had pj washington she got a bunch of
other dudes we'll never know about um
kendall's got it
she outperforms
this is interesting about her and you
gotta give her credit for this
she's not really taking down a list
but is spoken about like an a-list oh
wow yeah
who's she taking out a-list
usually the a-list they keep quiet but
she's the girl that uh dropped all the
secrets remember she's calculated with
it it's like i'll tell these guys
because they don't matter but the a list
is like hey look i'll keep your secret
so i can keep [ __ ] a little did a
superhead drop everybody
and she ruined her whole game and nobody
[ __ ] her no more yeah
because we talked about her like
superhead but super head gave way bigger
names than brittany randall ever gave
not that she didn't [ __ ] him maybe she
does it strategically but she's in that
class of thought
what did sue what is superhead doing now
we got to do an interview with her
she changed the game she changed the
game changed the game after that video
came out
so many girls tried the the basket weave
tech technique
that was her the indian burns
that changed the game you think she
invented that no move i think she's like
normalized
yeah yeah yeah remember when these girls
use their mouth just
i remember that when they would just go
mouth just that was crazy right oh no
paris hilton might have the best roster
okay go according to this article she
hooked up with
trophy winner
can i be honest with you when she came
out with that dick suck
keep in keep in mind this is eris
yeah she's gotta suck no dick in her
life no no but she wasn't famous though
she was just an arrow she don't matter
though like she's a legit heiress she
don't gotta suck nobody's dick if she
don't want to that's true and there's
gonna be dudes lining up to get some of
that hilton money yeah that's true so
apparently she still sucked dick good
she apparently took down cristiano
ronaldo yeah whoa oscar de la hoya whoa
brian urlacher yeah yeah andy roddick
who's a tennis player then former
heisman trophy winner matt lenart hmm
line art line yeah
the guy do a podcast with once a week
[Applause]
you